ten years ago facebook was the
up-and-coming social media company that
people couldn't get enough of mark
zuckerberg was the next child prodigy
like bill gates and steve jobs reaching
the billion dollar mark at just 23 years
old it seemed like he was going to build
one of the biggest companies in the
world and that's exactly what he did but
people aren't exactly happy with this
rise to the top
facebook's rise has been riddled with
controversy and privacy concerns and
this isn't surprising given that the
company's entire business model revolves
around selling user data to advertisers
in fact things have gotten so bad that
yahoo finance ranked facebook as the
worst company of 2021
despite all this bad press that facebook
has been receiving for years now the
negative perception never really hurt
their bottom line
people continued to sign up for whatsapp
and instagram and facebook was a stock
market favorite in mid 2021 facebook
even reached a market cap of a one
trillion dollars but unfortunately for
facebook this seems to have been a
significant top since then facebook has
had over 50 percent of their valuation
this correlates to a market cap loss of
584 billion dollars if you made a
company out of just their market cap
loss your company would be the ninth
largest company in the world considering
this i don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that facebook is part of the top 10
worst performing stocks of the s p 500
so how did facebook go from being a
silicon valley favorite to being one of
the worst performing stocks on the stock
market
one of the leading factors behind
facebook's recent downfall is a lack of
user growth in fact not only is
facebook's user base stagnating but the
first signs of a decline are starting to
surface in the last quarter of 2021
facebook had a net user loss for the
first time in their history shutting a
total of 500 000 users
this is extremely bad news for facebook
because it shows that even facebook is
not safe from being replaced
historically the social media space has
always been a fast moving world as
people jumped from one platform to the
next first there was friendster and then
we saw the rise of myspace followed up
by the explosions of twitter and
facebook after this initial web-based
era we saw a new era centered around
apps including whatsapp and instagram
and then snapchat and now tick tock
considering this rapid evolution
investors have always been wary of
investing in social media companies the
next big thing could become yesterday's
news within just a few years
for example y'all remember vine yik yak
or google plus
clearly things change on a dime within
the social media industry despite this
with facebook many investors felt that
things would be different as industries
mature they can support bigger and more
stable companies for instance just take
a look at google when they launched in
the late 1990s there were dozens of
different search engines on the market
and they each had a sizable user base
but over time one search engine after
another fell off the map and the google
rose as the winner
the same thing could be said about the
browser and email spaces as well
initially the crown was passed around
frequently but with the time there was
only one winner considering this many
investors felt that facebook would
become the google of social media and
facebook has actually done a tremendous
job at accomplishing this we just have
to take one look at facebook stock
versus twitter stock to understand just
how well facebook has done it even with
the recent decline despite this strong
performance over the years it has become
clear that facebook is not really
comparable to google you see with google
while they have completed dozens of
insane acquisitions over the years each
of these have expanded the business not
cannibalized the old business google's
original services including google.com
gmail and google chrome are all still
thriving parts of their business today
the same cannot be said about facebook i
mean if we're being honest who actually
uses facebook today the only reason that
facebook was able to grow for so long is
the strategic acquisitions of instagram
and whatsapp
this means that if facebook wants to
continue strong growth they have to
constantly acquire the next big thing
and this is simply not a very
sustainable business model i think
zuckerberg realized this several years
ago and that's why he slowed down on
acquisitions and is instead focusing on
vr and the metaverse these endeavors
have yet to really take off though and
in the meantime facebook's stagnating
slash declining user base is a massive
red flag that investors can't ignore and
this is causing them to leave in droves
aside from declining user numbers people
who are still using facebook's services
aren't exactly the biggest fans of the
company in fact the same people often
leave comments on youtube about how
facebook is the epitome of evo big tech
and given facebook's history this
reputation isn't all that surprising
likely the biggest red mark on
facebook's scorecard is the cambridge
analytica scandal if you're not familiar
with the scandal here's what went down
the story circles around a british
political consulting firm called a
cambridge analytica that was willing to
go to any lengths to win votes for their
clients
executives of the company were actually
caught on camera saying that they were
even willing to use bribes and
misinformation to help their clients win
votes
when this footage went viral the company
tried to downplay their intentions
suggesting that they would never
actually engage in such activities but a
whistleblower named christopher wiley
would soon prove that this was not the
case christopher revealed how cambridge
analytica's associates used a facebook
app to mine the profiles of 50 million
people cambridge analytica then turned
around and built software that was
specifically designed to influence
people's choices in elections i don't
think i need to explain why this is
morally shady and how it interferes with
free and fair elections and while it
wasn't facebook themselves that was
engaging in such activities it was their
platform that allowed this to even take
place
in fact facebook themselves confirmed
that cambridge analytica did not break
any policies when it comes to collecting
this data it wasn't until they
transferred the data out of facebook
that they broke facebook's policies as
you would guess people nor prosecutors
were exactly convinced by this reasoning
and they would crack down on facebook
hard
too often we see companies that have
committed terrible crimes walk away with
measly 100 or 200 million fines which is
insignificant compared to their profit
but with facebook the ftc imposed a 5
billion fine not only was this a
record-breaking fine but it was 20 times
larger than the previous largest privacy
and data security penalty now of course
a lot of y'all will argue that even this
is not enough for facebook but the ftc
did try their best and though facebook
was able to survive this nightmare user
sentiment has never been the same
in fact even individuals who have
literally made billions from facebook
have turned on their company including
whatsapp and instagram's founders likely
the most outspoken of this bunch is
whatsapp's co-founder brian acton whose
trade-up advocates for people to delete
facebook
given that such figures have turned on
facebook it's not surprising that stock
investors have also turned on facebook
even investors who are fundamentally
bullish on the company are cautious of
investing in the stock simply because
they don't want to hold such a
controversial company and unless
facebook changes this overwhelming
negative sentiment against them i think
it's going to continue to be quite a
difficult uphill battle for them
a lack of user growth paired with
atrocious user sentiment is already bad
enough but the nail in the coffin for
facebook was apple's privacy changes
last year in april of 2021 apple started
giving users the option to choose
whether they wanted to let apps track
their activity and as you would guess
basically everyone chose to prevent apps
from tracking their activity within just
a few weeks of this feature launching 96
percent of users opted out of app
tracking and honestly i think that the
four percent that did allow tracking
might have pressed a lot accidentally
and given that 97 of facebook's revenue
comes from advertising it this was
extremely bad news in fact facebook
projects that apple's privacy changes
will cost them 10 billion revenue just
this year at first facebook tried to
fight against these changes they tried
to convince people to press allow and
there were even rumors suggesting that
facebook was preparing an anti-trust
lawsuit against apple but i think
facebook eventually came to a
realization this was a battle that they
could never really win even if they took
apple to court and won the lawsuit this
would just make users resent them even
more leading to even greater losses in
revenue instead it looks like facebook
has chosen to take a similar stance to
snapchat ceo evan spiegel evan insists
that even though these changes are
brutal for the business in the short
term it's needed for the industry in the
long term and this is a very important
point because the truth is apple's
privacy changes last year are likely
just the first of many ten years ago
most people didn't know how companies
like facebook and google made their
money and frankly they didn't care they
were able to use a great service for
free and that's all they cared about but
as more of these quote-unquote free
services into the market people have
become quite aware of the inner workings
of these companies and most people
aren't big fans this has caused privacy
to become a focal point amongst
customers and the newer social media
companies aren't focusing on being free
but rather being private take signal for
example signo is a non-profit encrypted
messaging service created by one of
whatsapp's co-founders brian acton and
as of the end of 2021 it has a total of
40 million active monthly users now of
course this is just a small percentage
compared to whatsapp's 2 billion active
monthly users but with people like elon
musk supporting signal i think signal's
user count is only going up also i don't
think signal is just some anomaly either
rather i think it's the beginning of a
trend towards private social media
services which again spells disaster for
facebook
despite all the shortfalls surrounding
facebook's social media business all
hope is not lost for the company given
the enormous size of facebook they have
at least 10 years to figure something
out and change the direction of the
company and given that mark has been
working on steering facebook away from
social media for years now it looks like
he's on top of this issue he even went
as far as changing the entire company's
name which is usually something you
never want to do for brand recognition
purposes i guess you realize that their
brand facebook wasn't doing the company
any good
looking forward it it looks like the
main goal seems to be growing their vr
business and the metaverse which is a
pretty solid bet given that this does
seem to be the next big thing it looks
like even apple is betting big on ar and
vr technology but something to note is
that even if vr is the next big thing
there's no guarantees that facebook will
come out on top just because they're the
first people there
after all facebook themselves was not
the first social media company in the
world with that being said though being
large and the first does have its
advantages so we'll just have to wait
and see do you guys have a positive
opinion on facebook comment that down
below
also drop a like if you're a fan of the
trend towards privacy and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one